[Music]
hey everybody we're back again yeah
people probably get sick of looking at
our students every single day
deadly blessing yeah gently put jenny
put me through this one last night
i didn't mean to yeah
it should have been a good movie it kind
of had a lot of recognizable people in
it and orders porg9 the acting was
pretty good had a young sharon stone in
it yeah it was one of her first i don't
think it was her first movie but it was
kind of her first big role had a bunch
of little hotties in it
and they were pretending to be
mennonites and
or what were they they weren't making
tights
i think they were supposed to be amish
but they didn't want like the amish to
get mad at them it's like how would the
amish know they don't go see movies or
see [ __ ] on tv so they wouldn't well it
involved the devil and stuff
this goes along with all the [ __ ]
devil stuff and incubus
this one has a aquebus in it
it's [ __ ] lame though
and uh it's got the dude from the hills
have eyes
michael berryman yeah yeah he's in it
for about five seconds yeah he should
have been in the movie i feel like that
whole admit dude made a whole career out
of [ __ ] playing villains and he's the
sweetest [ __ ] in the world have
you ever seen any uh
interviews with him he's just a nice guy
seemed like a really nice man yeah he
had some kind of genetic disease which
made his face look like that
and uh
i just thought he was cool looking yeah
have dilly pop there with the ladies
that's what being school looking yeah
but uh
this movie here
is a drag
i mean i feel like it does have its
defenders i mean look even slasher
friends said this movie isn't underrated
uh and mega says agree not the greatest
but a lot of fun i don't know i kind of
here's the thing
i'm
95 sure that i saw this movie
on cable back in like the mid 80s or
something like that i'm sure i'd seen it
because i was kind of into wes craven
stuff
but
when i was watching it i don't think i
remembered a single goddamn thing so i
said well if i did see it back then then
it obviously didn't really make an
impression and watching it again i can
kind of see why it makes no impression
it's very very bland
yeah it was just like really i mean
there was some good ideas in there yeah
just didn't deliver but i kind of feel
like a lot of it just was like really
dragged and you guys know like i'm you
know i'm patient if you want to do a
slow burn or something like that i'm
there for it but this one just seemed
like
a little bit of a slog to be honest and
a lot of stuff i i feel like too it's
weird because it seemed like a slog on
the one hand but then on the other hand
it seems like it had too many ideas like
too many things going on like it could
have been streamlined needed some
special effects needed a monster
needed some paranormal [ __ ] to [ __ ]
happen
it was just kind of boring
which that's bad when a movie's boring
it's bad yeah it feels it has a good
cast
it does it does um ernest borgnine is
great in it looking like um you know one
of the one of the who's down in whoville
yeah and
i liked him better as the goat head in
devil's reign though yeah but yeah so he
wasn't in an office of the apes yeah he
wasn't it enough either he played isaiah
yeah so the weird thing about this is
that sharon stone
is in it and we noticed that she was i
don't think she's top billed but i i
felt like she was billed ahead of the
woman
marin jensen that was actually
the star of the movie sharon sharon
stone's in it a lot
but she doesn't actually get there until
probably about 20 minutes in yeah you
know not about sharon stone i just
forgot about her she was a she was like
a 90s 80s and 90s thing
yeah
i had to make sure she was still alive
she's alive
yeah i was gonna say she's not that old
geez she's 10 years older than me yeah
because i mean all her when she was in
uh not
the what was that [ __ ] movie that she
was in where she spread her legs open
yeah it's just totally she basically
basic headstand basic instinct that was
only what like the 1992 yeah
that didn't really make a big impression
on me i really you know because of how i
grew up in the movies i was watching i
know her from [ __ ] total recall
yeah that's right yeah she looked great
at total recall i know you i know you
you guys who were boys when that [ __ ]
growing up seeing that movie she was
smoking hot
yeah a couple people are agreeing with
you yeah smoking hot and [ __ ] that
was when she was like at her hottest
then she kind of got she went mainstream
and kind of got boring it was just she
was better when she was a b-movie sci-fi
queen
i kind of feel like that's true of most
actors
yeah they seem like they're having more
of a good time yeah well the thing about
this one okay so if you've never seen
this movie i had totally forgotten what
this was about i think what i might have
done well i know i didn't do this
because i remember wes craven also made
didn't he make deadly friend like maybe
a year a couple years after this
and all i remember that that was the one
where christy swanson is a robot or no
she's she dies and then like a weird
like the weird kid next door that has a
crush on her puts like a computer chip
in her head and brings her back as a
robot or something and she kills mama
fratelli with
from the goonies with uh basketball by
throwing her head and her head explodes
which is an awesome scene one of the
best horror scenes of the 80s
so i had totally forgotten what this
movie is about this movie is almost
a folk horror movie
but then it's also kind of a slasher
and then kind of like a supernatural
mystery and i feel like it doesn't
really come down into any one of those
camps enough to like like i said this
has too many ideas i'm not going to
blame wes craven entirely because
he didn't write this movie um he was
just kind of like this
it wasn't a case where like nightmare on
elm street or something like that where
it was like his movie like you know he
wrote it he came with the idea and
everything this one i think had already
like the idea for it was already out
there like the script had mostly been
written and he was just hired on to
direct it you know what i mean i agree
with you it's watered down
yeah so it has some cool [ __ ] in there
but it's not committing to anything but
it's not yeah and there's just too much
weird stuff going on that doesn't make
any sense and like a lot of stuff that i
don't know i just feel like it could
have been trying to go down the middle
of the road for some for some reason and
maybe it's trying to be realistic or
it's trying to give you realism or
something i don't really know
uh what they're trying to do with it but
it missed all the marks this could have
been a really over-the-top
good horror movie
with a bunch of [ __ ] in it that
you'd remember like children of the corn
or something like that yeah which is
which is also bad but you remembered it
but you remembered it just because some
of the [ __ ] was so ridiculous yeah
yeah yeah
and in back in the days you could put
that you know on constant rotation on on
cable and kids would grow up watching it
and it would be a classic because the
only thing that you know what we
remember was ridiculous [ __ ]
because it made an impression it was
crazy
yeah and that's what i would have done
with this i'd have made this [ __ ] crazy
it would have been like i felt like this
here's the thing i kind of feel like
the end of it was crazy yeah but then
like you didn't do anything crazy for
the whole movie so then the fact that
you come out like bust out like in the
last year there's too little minute
and you're just kind of like hey it's
crazy um i'm just kind of like no you
either should have made the whole movie
like that
or not ended it like that because if
you're gonna make it like normal boring
like realistic all the way through and
then pull that [ __ ] out at the end then
that then it's just stupid because it
doesn't make any sense i mean you could
have gone full on raw head wrecks where
you're not really working with anything
you're just [ __ ] going crazy with it
you know because and the monster has
googly eyes because
they weren't working with a whole lot
there but you didn't forget it
sure olivia did not forget that movie
enjoyed it
it was a kid enjoyed it like oh yeah i
yeah see i'm always a big advocate of if
you don't have a big budget and you have
like kind of a crazy idea like push it
lean into it make it as crazy as
possible because if you just make it
kind of if you're trying to make it a
good movie
um you know or a quality movie or
something like that and you don't really
have the budget or the talent or
whatever to do that time or the time to
do that then just make it ridiculous
make it
off the [ __ ] wall and then
even if it's terrible then at least
people will remember yeah
i mean [ __ ] raw head rex
kind of an objectively [ __ ] sucky
movie it is very sucky but
it tried and after that movie was over
we were still talking about it
weeks later yeah
it's ruffle but it's entertaining we'd
make a wrong hand
reference you know baptize me
like that you know and people would
[ __ ] look at people
baptize me you know
that's [ __ ] i don't know what i
remember we were saying that [ __ ] but i
don't remember what we were talking
about we definitely weren't pissing on
each other
i hope not no yeah because i wouldn't go
around saying that to like a random
group of people because you never know
somebody that's really into like clyde
barker movies might be that [ __ ] [ __ ]
stuck in our heads you know what i mean
and it was an effective movie even
though that thing had big old googly
eyes we didn't we gave a single [ __ ] we
didn't care
we didn't care that that movie sucked
we still liked well yeah there's other i
mean there's a lot of movies that i
realize objectively suck
yeah but that are still like wildly
entertaining yeah this is not one of
them i have to say [ __ ] that monster
running around in this heavy metal
outfit yeah
i felt like okay what i wish that that
he would have done like wes craven like
i said i'm not blaming him entirely
because this was not his movie he
already got the thing producers kind of
[ __ ] with them at least as far as i
know
they're the ones that actually made it
go like uber supernatural at the end
i kind of feel like what they should
have done
is do something like i mean if you don't
know what the story is i'll just kind of
give you a brief synopsis but it's kind
of about these this rural i don't even
know where the hell it's supposed to be
but it's like there's real rural like
the amish or something but they're
called hittites and they're super super
conservative they don't use any machines
or they don't nothing like that you know
what i mean
so they live out here now there's a guy
named jim who used to be a hittite but
he left and he went out to like sinful
la or something and he married this girl
and then brings her back
to live there and she kind of likes it
but everybody nobody likes her
so the whole thing about it is that all
of the hittites think that there's an
incubus
that the new uh wife whose name i can't
remember
martha that's her name um
that she's now they don't say that she's
an incubus because the incubus like i
said that's a male demon but that she's
the servant of the incubus right or she
contains or something yeah there's some
kind of lesbianic [ __ ] going on there
too i think well well the thing about it
is that here was something confusing and
i was watching another review of this
that and he said the exact same thing
i was like now i'm going to spoil the
ending so you know what i mean but this
is 1981 nobody's going to watch it say
don't cry
well there's a thing where
the the demon it's like there was this
one character who is portrayed as her
name's faith
and you think it's a woman the whole
time and then it turns out that she's
actually a man it's very sleep away camp
like the end of it but they don't really
go much into that but the thing about it
is that the scene where they revealed
that
like where they lay down they tear her
shirt off i didn't realize that they
were showing us that she was a man yeah
i just thought she was flat-chested
right you know what i'm saying yeah so
and i saw another review where he said
that too because he's like i didn't even
realize that she was supposed to be a
man until i read
something later and i was just kind of
like oh okay that's what they were
talking about she's definitely a she's
definitely a girl because the thing
about centralism the thing about
sleepaway camp is that at least they
committed and they showed like the
schlong yeah so it's like oh obviously
and yeah and the actor was a male what
what or was it no no no it was a body
double wouldn't it yeah that was a body
double
yeah so i didn't really get it until
like after i was just like what okay so
she's flat chested what do you want me
to do about that but then i was just
kind of like when i thought about it i
was like oh i guess they were saying
that she was a man the whole time
but
i don't know whatever okay so i didn't
really get that yeah that's we'll see
that's what i'm saying it just it wasn't
real clear like the way it was edited
um you know because
you know some women are flat-chested so
i didn't so it didn't immediately
well it didn't really immediately strike
me that it's like oh we're supposed to
see her chest and yeah and think she's a
man i'm just like i didn't if that
didn't occur there's one scene where
they kind of
they kind of hint the fact that that
there's a relationship going on between
the two of them
i don't know i don't know if that's just
the way i took it but that's we'll see
that's the thing well this is another
thing the movie is just very muddled
like i kind of understand it like what
happened but faith
yeah you think that she's kind of like
has a crush on martha like the whole
time because she's always kind of like
coming over the house hey i brought you
some eggs hey um this is a nice bedroom
you have here and like she sits on the
bed and bounces up and down and i'm just
like man she's really like uh flirting
hardcore but like i said it never
occurred to me that that might be that
it's a man right you know what i mean
yeah it never occurs i mean because
obviously that's you know that's the
actress is a is a woman but it didn't
really occur i just thought that she was
like i said like she was a lesbian like
that she and she was hitting on her i
was just like okay fair enough but it's
like maybe that was like weirder back in
the day like that people would have
jumped to the fact that it's like oh
maybe it's a man but that did literally
did not occur to me no i was just kind
of like oh well people did not pick up
on that back i was like oh she has a
crush on this other girl which like i
said that's not weird so i don't know
that's how everybody would have taken it
but yeah and and so like i said and the
thing when they tore off the thing i was
just like oh and she's flat chested i
was like what what are you showing me
and plus it was like really dark so i
kind of feel like
i wish that the movie would have picked
one of two directions
you could have gone the direction when i
thought this was how the movie was going
where the hittites
they were the ones that were just kind
of like hey cabarrus ichibis that's like
michael berryman i think like 85 percent
poor guy 85 percent of his dialogue in
this movie is ichibas he just like yells
it like all the time oh another people
incubus yeah well mostly that one woman
yeah i mean well he gets killed off like
pretty early on in the movie so he's
like not even in it that much sadly
because i love him but you know what i
mean so i kind of feel like i it would
have been cool if the hittites
had been like ooh incubus and like
believing in all this supernatural
[ __ ]
but then like faith and her mom
are actually serial killers which they
kind of are in the context of the movie
they're the ones killing all the people
right and there and there wasn't any
supernatural aspect so like the hittites
were like idiots because they were
accusing
this perfectly normal woman
who they didn't like of you know hosting
an incuba or incubus or whatever when
actually you know these people in their
own village were serial killers and they
were ignoring it because it's like oh
well they're kind of one of us or
whatever so you could have gone that
direction which was sort of like
criticizing the you know weird
superstitions or you could have gone
full-on superstition because i kind of
feel like the way they laid it out they
made it seem like the hittites were like
idiots for like believing in all this
supernatural [ __ ] but then the end
like this end that they pulled out of
their butt it they're right
you know what i mean there is an incubus
and it pops out the [ __ ] floor at the
end and like
and drags uh martha to hell didn't it
yeah it like pops out though i was just
like oh i was not expecting yeah it's a
little too late by then you don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah i kind of feel like yeah
they should that [ __ ] should have busted
out of there pretty early like raw head
wrecks and running around killing people
or something raping people what it
should have been doing
well that's kind of what happened in the
incubus yeah this is the movie we talked
about yesterday
but yeah well that was another one where
he said that i liked that movie better
actually but they probably should have
gone shown to monster more too that
movie the incubus was a lot better than
this one yeah it was um this one like i
said it actually could have it might
have been cool
just to like not even have the monster
but to have
the monsters be humans
but some but the conflict come from the
hittites believing that the monster was
supernatural you know what i mean so
that might have been cool if they could
have done that angle but then they went
like the
supernatural route at the end which like
i said is just proving that the hittites
were right
the whole time and there was an actual
ink to what i thought was really dumb i
was just kind of like i don't know come
down on one side or the other
um danny rowling said does sharon stone
get naked in this film no uh no she
wears like nighties a lot yeah and uh a
spider falls in her mouth if you're uh
into that sly says
sly said that he saw uh vivarium
oh yeah yeah he didn't see if he liked
it or not but uh yeah night gallery
meets twilight zone yeah it definitely
is it takes a couple times to it takes a
couple times of seeing that movie to
pick up on everything that's a good
flick
remember that kid the [ __ ] the kid
had the damn book that showed the weird
pictures and all the [ __ ] weird
writing in it yeah watching the
television
that's weird he's in an extra
dimensional nest [ __ ] having to raise
that thing's child it's a weird movie
yeah
you like to see art of self-defense next
that's you'll like that one
mango says as i recall craven was
ordered to reshoot the ending yeah he
was um like i said i don't think he was
super happy with it this is a movie he
doesn't really talk about very much
but it's strange because
some things that i've read about it said
that it was almost you could say that it
was almost like his most personal film
because i don't know if you guys know
but wes craven was raised in a very very
strict religious household
and that's why i kind of thought it
would have been more interesting
uh for this movie to have been more like
a criticism of the hittites like
behavior which it seems like it is but
then they're like vindicated at the end
which to me just seemed kind of weird
um but i don't know so like i said it's
strange because i feel like in the 70s
he was doing
um you know last house on the left and
the hills have eyes and he's doing like
all these really gritty like
nasty rapey kind of movies and he got
kind of known for doing that and then
this one kind of falls like right in the
middle like right before he started
doing his more successful stuff like
nightmare on elm street which only came
out like three years after this which is
a billion times better than this movie
interestingly deadly blessing has the
exact same
shot the very famous shot of um nancy in
the bathtub from nightmare and elm
street
through the first time right now street
with the freddy's glove coming up um
that shot was in this movie like almost
exact same shot except it wasn't
freddie's hand obviously it was a snake
like the you know snake came at the top
and that was another thing too there was
a lot of stuff about like snakes and
spiders that was one of the ways i guess
that the incubus was
tormenting
the people
like but just hey i'll throw a snake in
your bathtub or something like that
which seems a little bit
i mean if you're a demon it seems like
you could do worse than that
i mean a snake expensive a snake in your
bathtub i mean that might just happen
without any demonic intervention you
know what i'm saying like or a spider
like falling out off the ceiling into
your mouth or whatever and i think they
actually did put a spider in sharon
stone's mouth for that damn she was well
she was not happy about it she said well
i'll do it but only if you like remove
his fangs
damn she put that in their mouth like
that which if you remove the spider's
fangs well now the spider can't eat now
you have to give him little spider milk
shakes and stuff like that or he's going
to die yeah that blows goddamn chairs
although i don't really but i don't want
a spider fall out of my mouth either and
i actually kind of like spiders but yeah
so the thing about it i don't know i
just kind of feel like this really
needed
something it just
a lot of it like the shots are nice and
everything like that but there was too
much that was like not explained really
the whole
the whole issue could have been avoided
if because what happens is like martha
who is the woman that was from l.a or i
guess and she married this ex-hittite
guy and they moved back to this farm
which is called our blessing that's why
the movie's called deadly blessing and
he gets killed like
five minutes into the movie by getting
smushed by a tractor in an accident
which we know is not an accident so then
like she's mourning and her two
girlfriends come from l.a
one of them is sharon stone
and they're gonna stay there for a week
like while she's grieving they're having
like girls nights out and all this other
kind of [ __ ] and then like all of the
hittites are like not happy about it
they're like jezebels they're all like
intermittent or whatever so there's all
that going on but the thing about it is
that isaiah who's ernest borgnine's
character he comes to martha and says
hey i'll buy the farm off you
just get out of here like no why would
she want to stay there nobody likes her
they're always like [ __ ] with her all
the time because they think she's
possessed by an incubus
and
it's out in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere
and it's just like i don't really
understand like why you would stay you
know what i'm saying like in that
circumstance like i get like oh this is
the house that me and my husband were
gonna and she's pregnant so she's like
she says something about oh i made a
nest or something like i was like oh
gross but whatever she wasn't that
pregnant because she's still like skinny
as [ __ ] so i was like i'm sure you could
find someplace else like with the money
from the farm that they give you
so just get out of here and then you
would have to worry about it anymore
and i mean they could have left like
lots of times and they just never did so
it seemed like there wasn't i feel like
there wasn't a good enough reason for
the women
to stay there
you know what i mean especially when all
of the crazy [ __ ] started happening like
the there is actually one a couple good
effective scenes in this there's one
good scene where sharon stone goes in
the barn like to get some tool or
something like that and then like um you
know all the barn doors start like
closing and all the windows are closing
like they're surrounding the barn or
whatever and that's actually like pretty
creepy and she goes up in the hay loft
and there's spiders and she sees
somebody up there that looks like a grim
reaper type demony situation and she
sees that so that's actually like a
scary scene but you'd think after that
they'd be like yep we're out bye let's
get in the [ __ ] car they had a car
they came there in the car
and then there's like one of the other
chick that was there whose name i can't
remember but she actually kind of starts
falling for this other hittite who's
i guess was like
isaiah's other son so i guess jim's
brother
and he was like i don't know if i'm
really into this whole hittite business
and he was like how to arrange marriage
with his cousin or something and he
wasn't into it and
he wanted to like be a normal person so
this other girl like let him drive his
car so there was kind of like all these
little like weird romance subplots and
then it didn't come to anything because
they both get [ __ ] killed um you know
what i mean like everybody gets killed
so i don't know it's just this one
like i said i you know and if you like
it i'm not like [ __ ] on you or
anything like that it's just that
you know because everybody likes
different stuff and i know there are
some people because i've seen some other
people nobody is saying this is a
masterpiece i've never seen anybody say
that
um but some people do
like it because it's like underrated
which like i said that's fine
but for me
and i'm like i said i'm very patient but
this one this one tried my patience a
little bit i did finish it but i was
kind of
you know tom was just kind of like oh
and then he was just like he was like in
and out and i was just kind of like i
was gonna turn it off and then i was
like man it's getting so late and i
don't have time to watch another one
because i was gonna like turn it off and
watch another one it's not a terrible
movie it's just
it takes forever like to get where it's
going and there's just like so much
stuff going on in there that
really didn't need to be in there it's
not scary um
now some people have said that they
found like the bathtub with the snake
it's scary and like the the bits with
like the nightmares and the spiders
scary but i'm not scared of spiders or
snakes so neither of those were scary to
me so this really didn't have any scary
scenes um i will admit that the um
the demon popping out of the floor at
the end did like surprise me and i was
just kind of like oh okay you're gonna
end your movie like that but
the whole movie should have been like
that yeah i see why they called him in
to try to [ __ ] at least save the
ending of it probably because the movie
was original edit was probably torturous
to watch because
it was terrible i i didn't like it
yeah i didn't really like i didn't
really waste too little too late
just wordy and just meandering and just
going all over the place and just
just a very
stodgy bland
movie yeah like i said there's just too
much going on it's like
it really needed to be trimmed
down needed a bunch of special effects
it needed a reason to watch the movie
there is no real reason to watch this
movie i wouldn't watch this
i don't recommend it at all yeah i
definitely wouldn't re-watch it i mean
if you're a wes craven completist and
you feel like you need to see everything
of his yeah but
i don't know i didn't love it and like i
said i you know i was just having a hard
time like finishing it i was gonna turn
it off but but but like i said by that
point it was like too late and i was
just kind of like well i don't have time
to watch another movie so i'm kind of
stuck watching it now
but i i don't know i kind of feel like i
probably did see it back in the day but
maybe i wasn't really paying all that
much it's probably blotted it out maybe
or like got through it or like i said or
maybe i was like maybe i had it on in
the background and i was doing something
else so i wasn't really painting every
now and then i'd look up and go oh okay
cool whatever because i kind of feel
like i did that i used to like there's a
lot of movies like this yeah at this
time um and they're just long forgotten
and they were just bland stodgy movies
bulk movie that would just come and go
and make leave no impression
it's uh funny how wes craven's name is
attached to this
because usually those are at least
memorable but you know a lot of stuff
that he did i didn't like either you
know
there's a lot of other movies that you
know
like i wasn't really big into the into
the nightmare on elm street thing
oh the first one's fantastic i love
that's one of my favorite horror movies
of the 80s
just didn't like it as much and actually
it's weird because there's a lot of
you can see him working out some ideas
for nightmare noble street in this one
because there's a lot of [ __ ] in there
about
nightmares like sharon stone starts
having all these nightmares like i said
about spiders and the demon and
everything which again doesn't make any
sense it would make more sense
movie wise if martha was the one having
the nightmares why would sharon stone
have them because she just came the
shoes that will live there yeah so i so
like i said that there's just little
[ __ ] like that that doesn't make any
sense it just feels like it doesn't
really
gel yeah as a concept wes craven also
did the one with the center bites and
stuff didn't he
no no no did that one who directed
hellraiser well that was clyde barclay
barker yeah sometimes i get him confused
i didn't like i didn't like that either
i didn't like hellraiser oh i like how
razor yeah i didn't like it the sequels
weren't great but you know we'll see
them with nightmare elm street nightmare
on elm street one is amazing uh the
third one is also amazing
but the other ones are just kind of
so-so you know they're usually fun to
watch but i didn't really like funny
freddy yeah i like scary freddy and in
the first one he was scary like he made
a couple quips but not really like they
made him more like a comedian later on
and i thought that really undercut his
scariness remember the first time i saw
hellraiser i liked it first time i saw
it on repeat viewings i liked it less
and less and then i was like no this i
don't like this one and i realized when
i was young i only liked it because
some of the special effects sequences
were way ahead of its time and they were
kind of they had a real good visual
element for for its time the rest of the
movie i thought was just kind of bland
i mean it was very ahead of its time now
razer you had to think that came out in
like 1987. but what looking back on it
what blew it away and i wouldn't have
known because i didn't see it
um i would have really liked um all that
um
phantasm that entire series is good
yeah but yeah we brought that up before
manga said new nightmare was very good
yeah i agree i really did i forgot about
that one but yeah that uh new nightmare
was actually very good and then wes
craven actually directed that and he was
in it
um
playing himself because that was like a
meta yeah that was a really good idea i
liked that one a lot and you know wes
craven did scream which kind of like
that was jump started the whole [ __ ]
thing like in the 90s and that's
actually i didn't like a lot of the
movies that
um
ripped that off
but scream is that is real solid like
that's one of the more solid uh horror
movies from the 90s so uh somebody
mentioned people under the stairs yeah i
really like that one too
um and that's another one that i feel
like is a little bit underrated by wes
craven um generally like his 70s stuff
uh you know i love last house on the
left i love hills have eyes uh you know
early 80s
it was kind of hit or miss but then
nightmare on elm street and he really
like kind of hit the ground running and
you know
up until
that was really good and like i said he
also did a new nightmare so that was
good as well
um hugo said i liked the freddy's black
and white design on dream warriors yeah
my favorite sequence in dream warriors
was the kid like the comic book drawing
kid
like where he goes into his thing and
everything is like looks like a haha
video i was like into that we'll have to
we i don't think we've reviewed part
three have we
part three is good i mean the first
one's the best one but part three is
really good i just really liked all the
um characters in it and i liked like the
creativity that they went with each of
the characters like getting a really
crazy death like i i really like that
scene too where he like slats
slashes that guy's uh wrists and then
like pulls the
veins out and like walks them around
like a puppet like that as like and like
pulls him off a building
um
[Music]
pat hatfield said i remember hearing
that jordan peele wants to remake people
under the stairs yeah i'd heard that as
well i wonder if he'll ever get around
to it
i mean
that movie it's got problems but i
actually really like it i mean the
concept of it is just so [ __ ] weird
you know
it's about you know maybe so maybe
someday
um all right so i guess that's all was
there anything else i needed i thought
there was something else that i had to
oh one fun fact about uh deadly blessing
is that ernest borgnine was nominated
for a razzie the worst supporting actor
yeah
but you know what he was good he's fine
it's the best thing about the movie i
think he was kind of the best thing
about it they're just [ __ ] with him
because it was bad i mean the acting
wasn't awful uh sharon stone was
okay in parts but then i think she was a
little overwrought in other parts but
everyone else was just was fine i did
nothing stood out four of those girls
were in there as eye candy
pretty much yeah but they didn't do
anything with them
yeah they just mostly just laid around
in their negligees yeah like drinking
wine and shooting the [ __ ] and
everything like well somebody like
peered in a window yeah and they were
they were all cute yeah
the story wasn't worth it you know it's
just
yeah it was just it was just real dull
right it was just real dull i think that
was kind of the main thing it was it was
real dull and there was too much going
on yeah too much needless [ __ ] yeah
all right so
uh i guess we're done yeah so wrap that
[ __ ] up all right so it's tuesday so
tomorrow's wednesday so it's our main
show and this should be a fun one
because the show we're doing tomorrow
night is about florida pirates okay yeah
we're talking all about yeah the
pirate history of florida hopefully i'll
be feeling on top of my game tomorrow i
gotta get i'll get some vodka
yeah we're almost out of vodka i might
drink you know what tonight maybe i get
some rum yeah oh you know
we should get we should get rum because
it's pirates yeah
yeah that's a good idea actually i
hadn't thought about that yeah get some
rum and get some apple cider
we should get it and you can wear your
eye patch i got an ipad
and i got a [ __ ] wig and everything i
don't have a three-quarter hat well i
just have
not really no i don't think i do i have
any pirate paraphernalia i probably do
around here somewhere i have the more
[ __ ] ooh look i have this right here
yeah
i got that out of there
but yeah all right all right all right
so we'll be back tomorrow evening
talking about pirates
and uh so have a good rest of your
evening and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow